大家好,我是Seyoung
大家好,我是Crystal
現在是
宋蘇島的冬天
我們今天最後要去吃香蕉
我們現在要去找我們旅館的朋友了
現在這個大曆光很漂亮
好冷喔,冷到我眼淚都掉下來了
但是其實今天蠻冷的
今天現在只有五度而已
然後我們兩個居然只穿了這樣
我裡面是一件布拉套
然後再加一件就是
然後再加一件Marking King的皮外套
然後妳的呢?
我裡面就只有一件短袖
因為我現在沒有什麼衣服可以穿了
我這次來都把衣服穿完了
神經病
跟一件皮外
喔 蠻涼的
五度的天氣她裡面穿短袖
神經病
沒辦法 這次沒買什麼東西
就叫妳買衣服了
叫她多買一點
她需要打扮自己
我們剛剛早上用了什麼?
泡泡的 很像Roos的產品
對 然後它是一個保養品的彩妝
那個形容詞是這樣的
昨天韓國歐尼跟我們說的
然後昨天他就跟我說
如果他說
菜喲啊 保養品的彩妝
他沒有以後能做啊
他能做嗎
我們昨天用的那個
保養品的那個
保養品的美膏
真的蠻好用的
因為早上才上完妝
就是超級的透
我們剛到這間
昨天歐尼推薦給我們的
一個招募餐廳
然後它就是有送餅啊一些早午餐盤這樣
感覺蠻local的
再看一下今天的地圖
安妞哈嚕
我們哈嚕王爺來了
哈嚕的最後
最後的日子
一共二十六
謝謝
嗨!我是Krysta
我現在是Krysta的Channel
我把這個Channel搶走了
從現在開始由我接管
呃...
Caeyoung
我現在太忙了
差不多
你可以雙手伸直
然後再往後多一點點
你的胸椎的旋轉的角度可以再多一點點沒關系
有趣的有趣
訂閱 讚好 按讚
探索中
這是探索中
酷
我第一次看到美式館長這樣耶
我剛看完那個展覽了
覺得蠻酷的
這個展覽有很多很酷的地方
就是因為它有多了很多
真人實際上的互動
這個我覺得非常的酷
很像我在紐約看那種
古根漢博物館的感覺
蠻特別的
但是我覺得最特別還是人的互動
人的表演有非常多種
所以你可以很細微的觀察到
那你們現在聽到的聲音
應該就是那些人在
就是唱歌的聲音
好久沒有來漢南洞了
然後我就發現最近有一些
新出的店
然後這個是Rose Jenny同款
的衣服
我有在小紅書上面看到的
是新的耶
我的菜耶 這些滿辣的喔
店還有分兩層樓
走比較修繩風格為主的
漂亮
陽光折射進來的美
沒有穿過裙子
這裙子我沒有穿過
這誰啊
我覺得超適合你的
超適合我是嗎
哇
好新穎喔
連我自己都覺得很新穎
美式
首爾真的對我來說算是一個
非常輕鬆然後非常方便的一個地方
可能會講韓文
我覺得對我來說還是差蠻多的
就是來首爾旅遊
這件事情會讓我覺得說
在語言上面會有一種很有成就感的感覺
就比起如果去歐洲的話
要講英文這件事情對我來說比較困難
但是如果講韓文的話就會覺得
好方便蠻多的
這間呢就是漢南東新開的一間店
然後我也是第一次看到它
忘記是去年年底還是今年開的
然後綜合了很多品牌的一間店這樣
Martin King到底胖
到其他的Rotai的牌子都有這樣
這間不錯 蠻好看的
那個單身極地獄的金高恩的pick
然後就發現很多都是他的pick款耶
蠻酷的
我們晚上要去吃烤肉
但雖然是太餓了
我等不到那個時候了
就先點了炒年糕 然後魷魚
然後跟一個Sundae 血腸
我要來吃吃看他家的Dobogi
我是Dobogi愛好者
超愛
哇 很好吃耶